you stop and you think about everything
we hold a value on this planet metals
minerals energy real estate the things
that nations fight wars over these
things are in near infinite quantities
out there if you believe that the
developing world deserves the same
standards of living that we do in the
developed world then to achieve that
they need resources they need the metals
and the minerals to build the industries
and the buildings and so forth and the
energy and the question is do you
continue to rape and pillage earth or if
you had the ability to extract that
information from the outside resources
outside of Earth then that would be a
mechanism to uplift the bottom billion
or so of society the other thing is that
there's a concept that a friend of mine
Elon Musk and I talked about backing up
the biosphere you know go back to
ancient history and when the libraries
of Alexandria burned and all the
knowledge was consumed in those flames
today we have built this pinnacle of
information both in the biosphere
encoded in the genomics of plants and
animals and the billions of species on
this planet and in the internet where
we've digitized languages information
and images and so forth you know the
right-sized asteroid coming in to smack
the earth will destroy all of that so we
have today literally the technical
capability to back up the living earth
if you would back up Gaia digitally and
to go in sequence the genomes of not
billions but millions of species and
take that information and duplicate it
off the planet such that if anything
ever happened its resident there and
preserved forever that sort of
capability comes with it a tremendous
moral imperative in my mind of being
able to implement this so those are some
of the reasons to uplift society and to
back up the biosphere and the third and
final reason is its
in our genome we are as humans exploring
species you know we began the plains of
Africa and our need to explore that took
us into Europe into Asia across the
Straits into the Americas and so forth
that drive to explore is resident in our
DNA in fact it's genetically if you
would select it for because those who
explore and move out the widest and
farthest have the least chance of having
their genome
you know destroyed by a local accident
and so that is a evolutionary imperative
we're not going to stop here on planet
Earth we're going to move out to other
planetary bodies and not I believe not
going into the planetary you know
gravitational wells will build societies
and in you know one'll like spheres and
and humanity will move out into the
cosmos and probably meet other societies
that have done the same and millennion
eons past
something very interesting has happened
over the last hundred years that people
don't think about which is that the
frontiers that we have have started to
shrink and disappear it used to be that
a hundred or 150 years ago if you
screwed up you know you up
literally in one area you're you could
go and start again someplace new you
could go and and start your life again
without the stigma of what happened
there's no place you can do that again
there's no real frontiers so that
ability the second thing about frontiers
are it allows the individuals who are
best whether they're men or women or
minorities or whatever to to step up to
the top so in traditional societies you
know old-world societies in the you know
the United Kingdom if you would if you
were born into the right Stratus the
right class you had the ability to
succeed but if you weren't you were
stuck and in the frontier and it didn't
matter what your birthright was where
you went to school what you did if you
are the best people came to you so
that's some of the elements of a
frontier and finally in space what's
going to happen is the chance to truly
explore in different societal structures
if you want to practice a pure
capitalist state or Anarchy or socialism
whatever it is you can gather the people
around you who want to you know to form
that type of government and go and
create your own space society off on
some colony and go and practice that
knows who don't like it can duplicate
the genomics and the knowledge systems
of that colony and split out and do it
again there will be the Darwinian
evolution of different forms of society
and different ways of people trying it
but you know go and try and start your
own government here in the United States
today and you'll be squashed very
quickly
one of the precepts of the XPrize is you
get what you incentivize a very simple
concept that's extraordinarily powerful
and if you look to the root of what the
problems are you always find out well we
don't incentivize that today what we
incentivize we incentivize you know a
congressman be elected every two years a
president being elected over four years
and center over six years so it's what's
going to affect people right now you
know what can I promise and deliver in
two years space is not a two-year
objective it used to be in the early 60s
we had this eye candy of mercury and
Gemini and Apollo every year we would do
something more and more in it it met
those needs but the easy stuffs been
done you know and today NASA calls stuff
nominal instead of phenomenal like it
really is so you know I have given up
that that you know there's going to be a
balance and NASA's going to do certain
things and we are finally in a state of
existence where small groups of
individuals can do extraordinary things
funded by single people you know today a
group of 20 individuals empowered by the
exponential growing technologies of AI
and robotics and computers and networks
and eventually nanotechnology can do
what only nation-states could have done
before we saw this in the first XPrize
that we put together the Ansari XPrize
where a spaceship one built by a small
team of 20 individuals that scaled
composites led by Burt Rutan funded by
one individual paul allen did what you
know only the united states government
could have done 40 years earlier we see
that more and more coming up
you know I'm a nine-year-old kid inside
and my passion has been all my life to
want to travel to space I got I drank
that kool-aid I got that bug as a kid I
saw Apollo going on in TV I was born in
61 and I believed it was gonna happen I
believed that we were you know once we
got to the moon there's no stopping us
but in fact we did stop and you know
it's been literally 40 years since we've
been to the lunar surface and I ended up
realizing that NASA was unlikely to get
me into space or get me to the moon or
beyond and I needed some other way to
drive this and I became very much if I
have to describe myself I'm a sort of a
libertarian capitalist and I was looking
for what's the economic engine that's
gonna drive us into space so I received
a book one day from a great friend of
mine Greg Marion act called the spirit
of st. Louis that tells the story of
Lindbergh and I had no idea that
Lindbergh crossed the Atlantic to win a
prize I thought he woke up one day just
decided to go east but in fact there was
this Frenchman born in Paris came to New
York you know with pennies in his pocket
Raymond Orteig was his name became a
busboy moved up eventually bought the
hotel he worked at started in second
hotel and just after World War One when
aviation just started getting going he
became enamored by this idea of aviation
and he decided to put up a prize for the
first person that could go nonstop
between his birthplace and his his new
home in either direction but if he knew
about the trade winds you'd go east and
as it turned out nine different teams
from around the world mostly in the u.s.
mostly France went after this and the
nine teams spent four hundred thousand
dollars to win this $25,000 prize 16
times the prize man I'm going oh my god
and I'm making notes in the margins
about how much money is being spent
Admiral Byrd the first guy to fly the
North Pole for example spends $100,000
to try and win his $25,000 prize and he
crashes on takeoff because
he over weighs his over weights his
airplane with champagne and China to
celebrate when he lands in Paris as if
there would be no champagne in China in
Paris when it gets there and the most
unlikely guy to do this Charles
Lindbergh who'd been flying the mail for
just a handful of years makes this
effort no one would sell an airplane no
would sell him an engine because he was
unproven you know who is this guy
I mean for God's sakes we don't know who
he is I'm not gonna he's gonna kill
himself and set back aviation in a
decade well of course he does just the
opposite he makes the flight thirty
three and a half hours later he lands in
lebra che and he becomes famous
overnight and still today you know all
school kids know his name but what hit
me was not the efficiency of this prize
which was amazing right you put up
25,000 you get four hundred thousand
dollars spent to win it but that was in
18 months of Lindbergh making this
flight across the Atlantic something
miraculous happens we go from in 1927
where there was six thousand paying
passengers in all the United States and
people who flew in airplanes were called
aeronauts and Daredevils this is Eric
Lindbergh Charles's grandson is a great
friend on our Board of Trustees who
tells a story went from going being
aeronauts and Daredevils 6,000 of them
to 18 months later where they were
passengers and pilots and there were a
hundred and eighty thousand of them you
know this 30-fold increase this it is
kind of this prize caused this you know
dramatic change in the paradigm and that
inspired me to create the Ansari X PRIZE
for spaceflight and so that's how it got
started
so one of my goals is to reinvent
philanthropy you know today philanthropy
is a very unsophisticated old-world
process where you know people who make a
shitload of money go and give it away
and you know they're when they're making
their money they're focused on 10x
hundred X returns on the dollar every
dollar they use has got to be basically
leveraged but when they go and give
their money away they're happy with 30
cents on the dollar or ten cents oh they
really tried hard too bad they didn't do
it that's ridiculous you should command
and demand the tenfold leverage on your
dollars and you give it away as well so
we look for areas that are stuck you
know where there's a stigma where where
there is you know people have given up
that there can be a solution for it you
know in the space business space had
gotten very much to be the aerospace
industry this is something that
governments only do and it's for the
Boeing's and the Lockheed and the
Northrup's and so forth and there's no
way these small companies could do it
the automotive industry in the same way
so these industries have become old age
and they become you know osteophyte they
can't innovate themselves out of a paper
bag sometimes this is we're putting up a
clearly defined measurable prize that
says to the world
I don't care where you've gone to school
what you've ever done you do this and
you win and it brings really orthogonal
thinking to the table people who don't
have the degrees people who would never
get a National Science Foundation grant
because they don't have the you know
imprimatur or haven't done the research
but they may have the most brilliant
idea because they're not stuck in the
way they think it was Henry Ford who
said you know an expert is someone who
can tell you exactly how something can't
be done and that's true
we bring prizes together in a number of
different ways first of all we have our
board of trustees who we've built very
carefully it's a large number of really
self-made innovators you know Larry Page
Dean came in Elon Musk Ratan Tata from
from India the Ansari family that funded
our first and sorry XPrize incredible
individuals and then we have our vision
circle which are our largest benefactors
these are individuals like Sergey Brin
and Eric Schmidt again the Ansari family
stew blessing and these two groups our
board of trustees and our vision circle
members get together twice a year with
us so we have a vision earring session
and for two days we debate and we
discuss what are the world's biggest
problems where are they stuck you know
from diagnosing tuberculosis in three
hours from in remote areas to diagnosing
cancer early to mapping the ocean floor
or trying to deal with the ocean
plastics issue or reinventing education
and we debate and we discuss what would
make a great XPrize we have our XPrize
labs we have an X Prize lab at MIT at
USC and University of Washington and IIT
Bombay and these are interdisciplinary
graduate level programs where young
students who don't know what's not
possible come up and say let's create an
XPrize around this area and then the
staff the senior staff that really is
constantly thinking someone whenever I'm
meeting somebody I'm interviewing and
say what do you think a great XPrize
would be and brainstorming with over
lunch
so that's sources for ideas
you know end of the day the people who
end up funding our prizes are
corporations and philanthropists and
they end up literally you know if you're
a venture capitalist you interested
moving a technology forward you've got
to choose your horse ahead of time so
you're gonna if you're interested in
water technology energy energy
technology you get to choose between the
three or four companies that you have
insight into and you have to make a bet
on them before they prove anything out
and you don't know about the other
hundred out there that might have much
better technology and it seems really
silly to me to do it that way when you
put up a large incentive prize you get
the entire world so it pulls out of the
woodwork all hundred companies and you
get to see them all and you
automatically back the winner so you
know for me it's a very logical it's
highly leveraged ten typically 10 to 50
fold the amount of money you put up you
get spent by the teams to win it you're
creating a brand new industry and you
have full industry inside and in the
winning of the prize you create a brand
new marketplace and then is buying the
product that you incentivize in the
first place now Paul Allen who backed
Burt Rutan in a recent interview with
with Dave Moore who ran Paul Allen's
venture here you know Dave said that you
know Paul Allen invested somewhere
between 20 and 30 million dollars and
that he got probably you know five or
10x the money back by backing it in
terms of the licensing rights and the
tax deferrals and the technology they
had developed and the media and so forth
so in this time when you know money is
tighter and tighter and tighter you know
we believe that incentive prizes are an
extraordinarily efficient way for
companies to drive breakthroughs in
their industry you've got companies like
Netflix and Cisco and others creating
incentive prizes inside their company or
in their area to drive you know to say
gas yourself the question do you have
the smartest people in the world working
for you
company and if you do you're lucky but
if you don't put up the incentive you
know we get what you incentivize and
cast it out to the world and have
someone who is absolutely brilliant
who's you know a 22 year old in India
who says what about this way and who
revolutionizes the way you do business
we become stuck in the way we think we
have to we as you know the leader in the
field has been doing what they do all of
their lives and when someone comes in
with something that is extraordinarily
risky they have a lot to lose and so
their willingness to take the risk is
very low but when you bring people in
who got nothing to lose they're
literally willing to risk their lives
that's where breakthroughs come in the
day before something is truly a
breakthrough it's a crazy idea
so the question companies have to ask
where governments have to ask is where
do we allow crazy ideas to bubble up
because if there's a failure what
happens someone gets blamed there's a
lawsuit there's a congressional
investigation and so those things shut
down the creative engine one of the
people who have a tremendous level of of
gratitude for and an excitement about is
Ratan Tata the chairman of Tata
industries you know they give out an
award every year for the team and their
company took the biggest risks that's
going to drive innovation so you get
what you incentivized and I do believe
that the best way to predict the future
is to invent it yourself so that's what
we do we drive people to invent the
future they want to create by
incentivizing it
one of the companies I co-founded is a
company called space adventures and we
are the only company to date to have
flown people privately into space we
have flown eight passengers to the space
station going up on the Soyuz Dennis
Tito was our first richard garriott
who's the chairman of space adventures
and a trustee of the XPrize foundation
for a second-generation astronaut and
our latest was Gila Liberty the founder
and CEO of Cirque de Soleil these people
spend about forty five million dollars
to go up for ten days to the space
station incredible experience if we
could buy a seat on the shuttle which we
cannot the cost per seat probably one
hundred million dollars in the shuttle
so the Soyuz is is somewhat somewhat
cheaper if you went and we had a super
efficient system the cost
I think you'd ever the closest you'd
ever get down is probably in the four or
five million dollars per seat using
existing propulsion systems if your
whole system was reusable and if you
flew it on a very frequent basis but if
you go and you do the energy
calculations of how much it cost to put
you and your space suit into orbit you
know high school physics student can do
this it's easy it's mass times gravity
times height to get your potential
energy and then one-half MV squared to
get your kinetic energy and if you do
that for you and you're in a two hundred
kilogram spacesuit turns out the total
energy spent over an hour is about 1.6
Giga joules and if you bought this off
the electric grid at 7 cents a kilowatt
hour the cost of getting you and your
spacesuit into orbit is about a hundred
and twenty bucks so the price
improvement curve ahead of us is 45
million to 100 bucks that's a pretty big
motivation
I'm not naive enough to think that we're
not gonna have amazing physics
breakthroughs I mean dude
technologically we've been a
technological species for a hundred or
200 years depending on where you you
measure that so I think there is much we
do not know but in the near term I'm
betting on a technology which i think is
very doable today in fact I'm in the
middle of talking with a number of
benefactors about creating an XPrize
around this concept it's called beamed
power propulsion and the concept is
today rockets haven't changed in the
last two thousand years since early
Chinese rocketry you have a tube you
burn something inside and the hot gases
come out one end that's you know they've
gotten bigger more expensive more
elaborate more efficient but there's
still the same basic concepts so one of
the XPrize ideas and I'm excited about
that I really want to have is called
beam power propulsion the way it works
is you have a source of energy in the
ground either lasers or probably
microwaves and that system is getting
more and more efficient every year the
price to generate a megawatt or a
gigawatt of Energy's coming down year
after year we're learning how to print
it make it more efficient and what you
do is you beam the energy to the rocket
and the rocket basically converts that
energy to heat and heats up a working
fluid like hydrogen and then the
hydrogen goes out the other end that can
reduce the cost of spaceflight by 50 to
100 fold and it's technology that could
be done right now but no one's doing it
because no one's doing it and that's
when XPrize really comes in if you can
demonstrate something just enough like
for example with the original Ansari
XPrize for spaceflight we demonstrated a
ship carrying three people up 200
kilometres twice in two days and then
Richard Branson comes in and you know
says I'd commit a quarter of a billion
dollars to commercialize that technology
so I'd love to demonstrate beam power
propulsion and once that's demonstrate
enough then new technology will come in
every prize that we design has to meet
certain attributes number one clear and
measurable three people 100 kilometers
100 mile per gallon or its equivalent
car you know with x-parameters sequence
100 human genomes in 10 days the second
thing is it has to be addressing a grand
challenge it has to be something which
could have a paradigm change on the
backend the third is if it's properly
designed when it's one the world is
paying attention and it ignites a new
industry for me
the fact that Branson was there
committing the money
and all of a sudden people started
buying tickets you know they've been
over a thousand tickets sold to fly into
space was what made this really exciting
uh yes spaceship one is hanging in there
and Space Museum right above Apollo 11
next to spirit of st. Louis that's great
but the fact that we have an industry
going is what makes it awesome so
another thing is I'm looking for prizes
or winnable in three to eight years in X
prizes if it's less than three years was
too easy more than eight years no one
gives a anymore the other thing
though is we are now creating something
we call X challenges X prizes are these
bigger ten million dollars or more the X
challenge is our million dollar level
prizes that are more winnable in a year
or two years or about moving technology
forward in an in a demonstratable
fashion
the paradigm I want to change is that
you can have a car that is beautiful
manufacturable affordable safe fast and
oh by the way does over 100 miles per
gallon or two energy equivalent why
wouldn't you so we put out this
competition we had a hundred and thirty
five hundred thirty six vehicles
register to compete weird and whittled
it down out of fifty one vehicles
there'll be a few winners and at the end
of this besides having a few winners
three winners in particular for the
Progressive Automotive XPrize my goal is
there's a new generation of cars and
people can say we're living in a new day
of age new day and age of cars that are
beautiful affordable safe and of course
every car gets over a hundred miles per
gallon why wouldn't it so that's a
game-changer a change in the paradigm a
change in the kind of cars that we drive
another game-changer is another XPrize
I'm itching to get launched and it's the
autonomous car XPrize I think a hundred
years from now people will look back and
say really people used to drive their
cars were they insane you know humans
are the worst control system to put in
front of a car you know we for these 100
millisecond delays you know we our
attention is on our PDA we're you know
we're always in a rush you know we drive
around in these four thousand pound
metal wombs you know these four thousand
pound containment systems to protect us
from these six thousand pound cars from
smacking us and you know I'm gonna buy a
uh you know a you know a large SUV
because I'm scared about the other SUVs
I'm gonna buy this small little car make
it gets lemon of course they're right in
that regard but if we can build
autonomous cars that are so smart and so
sensitive to what's going on that they
can't be hit then you're thinking when
cars have the sensory systems around
them
GPS intelligence they're looking at the
world not only in visual spectrum but
infrared and ultraviolet everything else
that's going on and they've got reaction
times
and you know microseconds not you know
not a tenth of a second there you know a
hundred thousand times faster then
you're talking three things come out of
it today they're about two million major
injuries
fifty thousand loss of lives the United
States alone you'll get rid of those
first and foremost if you care about
saving fifty thousand lives that's one
option the second thing is cars will get
a lot lighter because they're not
worried about it so you know you don't
need four thousand pounds a thousand is
plenty and if you're carrying around you
know the idea of a you know a young thin
woman who weighs 100 pounds driving
herself around in a 4,000 pound SUV is
laughable so she doesn't need that a
thousand pounds is plenty to give you
all the accoutrements in the room and
such so you reduce the energy usage by a
large factor and the third is on all
these autonomous cars know where all the
other autonomous cars are they can fan
out and they take the most efficient
route to get you foreign place and you
got rid of traffic jams eventually
frankly no one's gonna own a car what
you're gonna own is on your PDA the
ability to say you know I need a car
from here to here and you can say I need
a car now in which case they'll charge
you a premium or I'm willing to pay
fifty cents for that drive in which case
the car William to take you 50 cents or
I need a Ferrari because I'm on a date
and you've got this panoply of cars that
you can choose from and you you will own
the ability to command transportation
not the need to have a car so those are
the futures there
of energy has come on as a major partner
for the progressive automotive x prize
and I'm extraordinarily thankful to them
for that I think that there is a lot
more that the government can do but it's
a start the idea of of create starting
to envision the rules and regulations to
allow for autonomous cars is a hard one
think about when we had when I did the
Ansari X PRIZE originally the rules or
regulations to allow for private
spaceflight didn't exist you know you
could not legally put a human and fly
them into space in fact you couldn't
bring a spaceship back all the space
vehicles we were sending commercially a
space or one-way you know you sort of
like got rid of them and most passengers
who go up do want to come back down so
we had to go and change the rules and
regulations and the in the momentum of
the competition allowed us to do that so
I imagine there'll be new rules and
regulations on the autonomous car XPrize
I didn't mention what some of the two
ideas the autonomous car XPrize one is
the first car to win against the
top-seeded NASCAR or IndyCar driver so
it's really you know the the deep-blue
equivalent from the you know chess world
in the automotive space and the
alternate would be the first car to go
autonomously from LA to New York in
under three days obeying all the rules
and regulations I'd have a heck of a
time going through state lines and local
police and all that but anyway those are
two concepts looking for again a
dramatic demonstration of autonomy
showing itself to be far more safe than
worrying about whether the person on the
street next to you is texting or has had
a drink or is paying attention
what can go wrong is that we can become
landlocked you know one of the things
that's going on right now is that we
have this amazing debris cloud in space
orbital debris as it's called where
you've had anti-satellite weapons
blowing up satellites you've had old
satellites decommissioned left in orbit
and other satellites smacking into them
every time there's a collision hundreds
of parts break off and these these
components are traveling at 17,000 miles
an hour so they're you know much faster
than speeding bullet and their reaches a
point at which all this debris starts to
grow exponentially and we will literally
have this will be locked in or sending a
spacecraft up to space to get through
the debris cloud we'll be taking your
chances so solving that is another
XPrize that we've talked about one of
the other major things I think to really
incentivize and open the space frontier
we need to allow for ownership you know
what opened up the America West it was
the fact that you owned the real estate
you owned the gold mines the oil wells
you know the creation of these back then
million million dollar industries drove
the railroads and eventually even the
airlines to provide this kind of
transportation so I'm extraordinarily
passionate for example about the idea of
asteroid mining in the future and
asteroids out there we know them from
those that have fallen on the earth
there is a class of asteroids a subclass
of nickel-iron
asteroids which are 50,000 times more
enriched than platinum mines on earth
extraordinary off that can be great the
first trillion eros made in space the
question is do we have the structure to
allow for the ownership of these if we
do or when it's finally created we will
have really the impetus the real market
creation that will cause billions to be
invested privately in space
transportation to gain access to the
trillions that are out there